my weight I coach tassels oh yeah my
boys head coach the great the great
coach ruvik he taught him off or texted
me immediately after our last episode
and he's a big t fat K fan and he said
um Mario Lopez would beat the [ __ ] at
Frank Grillo and I said you you Ty's
instructor but you wait one second
disrespect there needs to be a celebrity
right now especially if they were to
meet you know when the Frank is I'm
putting all my money on Frank and I know
Mario Lopez can box yeah I'm putting
like my all Mikey yeah I'm putting all
my but you know what Frank's just
tougher he's just tough that's probably
true Frank Christ I'm tough he's just
any nose box and he fought I know for a
fact when he was younger he fought every
weekend and also Frank if you broke his
nose he won't give a [ __ ] you break
Mario Lopez
Lopez's nose yeah what do you think is
gonna happen no you're right I mean I
see you tell you in Streisand we're in
the boxes every day with three guys
chris van Heerden
a high level boxer slaughter Oh Spence I
mean guys Brian Phil area you know Brian
from area let's go easy on the term
fight no no I'm saying he does spark he
does works out with them the trains far
I've seen the spar
he's not gonna blow for blow with no no
no you never say an actor is going
before my god like Chris man here take
it easy
come on have to just watch lush we do
here of course Jim here but but but
really studies the art of box these
obvious I've seen the guy worked out
even when I was in when I was fighting
he'd be in there I'm telling it he'd
outwork me yeah I and he was and he
spent a he was obsessed with jujitsu and
there's also crazy and he's crazy he's
like a real tough guy like he's a really
tough guy you know like I make fun of
Hollywood for being tough guys Frank
stuff he'll fight you right now so we
were having this conversation on the
last jason ellis show who wins a
celebrity fight if it goes down it
old-school UFC style no weight classes
you fight you continue going on like a
bracket okay tournament style multiple
fights in the night if joe counts he
wins right rogon row against who
celebrities celebrity the wall
celebrities i told you just a legit
black bow right i mean kick like a
[ __ ] lunch and he's all yes
no other celebrities yeah well okay we
got to throw in Frank I mean I'm just
thinking people who could even Joe Joe
time and knots Frank dunno that's the
thing it's like I'm just think about the
reality of a real MMA fight we're sure
if it's just converted to stand back and
exchange blows there's one but in the
ground Joe's the best by far the best
celebrity grappler like we're sure but
but also joking kit [ __ ] like crazed
and ups good too
yeah he can back kick those spinning
axes you take one of those who sternum
it's your dime hot leg I don't know that
I have to know the other celebrities
because yeah it has to do with who can
take a punch to your you can kick and
punch cause right hand off tossa Chris
Hemsworth in there
I saw him boxes boy oh really oh it's a
big boy too I will say the first size
right bigger than me I will say the
hollering leaner
that's a better looking no one can throw
kicks period that isn't a professional
fighter
Chris Hemsworth his Muay Thai look it
looked okay like never seen what I've
seen in his kickboxing in person yeah
and I walked in gym I saw his big ass I
did
I didn't register that was Thor and I
went I thought it was a maybe a new
sparring partner for me I was like who
the [ __ ] that in the ring back there
like that's doorman's like let's see
Spence was a cool guy let me tell you
how I know has he has he ever sparred or
fought though Brennan I don't know he's
never door so I'm not worried about it I
think was the outdoor one chin yoga like
his his throw your kicks different see
that's not bad it's not good that's also
three years ago but he's getting on her
balance big guy never has he sparred
what happens when he gets Chad in the
[ __ ] nose there are a lot of things
love fighting so different than hitting
myths hitting oh yeah literally
different sport I'm not talking about
him in a fight I'm talking about that
fact that we receive him try to throw a
kick it looks so bad and that wasn't it
oh that's a struggle most celebrities
right I can see any celebs get punched
in the face Brian so Stanford Brian
County and I'm not I think you have to
remove Brent
celebrities that were formerly
professionals I can you are out Randy
Couture's out obvious yeah spider it's
not fair
that mike tyson's out obviously look
he's an athletic guy doesn't think he
was that big he was at a storage unit
that I used to have my car parked a
stove a dad too
and this is how I know he's actually a
cool person he comes in with his wife
who is [ __ ] so so [ __ ] hot bring
her Upton oh my god celebrity relative
you just bust not tuner dude because
they have like six kids
he yeah I would be I would be a
never-ending stream of jizz inside her
because she is so ridiculously hot and
not a spring chicken and still looks
like that oh wow that's not a good
picture of her either
Oh what's a good leg there that oh
that's it that's a really and Chris
Hemsworth of course should have that
would you expect anything less
right right respect atutor I'm at the
good-looking guy I'm at this sorta
aspirin sitting down with the guy at the
counter like signing in and we're
bullshitting because I had my GTO parked
there when I used to have my my muscle
car and he was asking me about my car
we're talking and Chris Hemsworth walks
in with his [ __ ] wife and I'm like
I'm just trying to keep silent but he's
you know it's pretty impressive slippery
or yeah and he was getting looking at
the like selection of locks to put on
his storage unit and he goes uh what
happens if I lose the combination to
this one what's the difference in these
two and then one either guys like once
you know you comes with the key the
other one he's coming he said well what
happened if I forget my combination I
was like use a hammer Thor hmm you said
that and he goes what and the guy starts
a very fun and I and he goes what and I
go use the hammer of Thor and I'm
thinking oh this guy's gonna [ __ ]
smears yeah he goes that's good mate
that's good and I was like okay okay
Thor's there's a nice guy yeah she is
smokin yeah that's it that's a woman
he's got to send everything before what
is he something he's just viking up to
he's a he's a Aussie isn't he yeah
Australian ice brother
that's a good it's a poontang Haven to a
lot of a lot of attractive you have you
been
that was a little kid but I just like
obviously the media allows me to know
that there's a tremendous amount of poon
it's really coming out of Australia some
of those pretty girls in the world oh
you don't remember her in Fast and
Furious she's hot fashion whew oh okay
okay 37 years old watch the first one
then when they start jumping off
buildings and the rocks like holding a
GTO by his [ __ ] right hand out of a
helicopter like I'm out how well does
the what shoot Elysium see celebrity bra
20 before he got CRO because of his size
and he looked the man I think University
of Miami he's not he's not he's a legit
athlete he's got some toughness and he's
[ __ ] huge Samoan while a huge now
he's probably not gonna make for the
most Christmas Stryker because of his
balls me stuff but if you get to hold
you that's a gigantic man that is lifted
by profession you gotta talk about
weight classes right or we just not when
you can with celebrity most celebrities
off my size there's a small Rogan would
choke the rock down exactly easily yeah
very quickly very quickly yeah yeah I
give some current events you teach the
rocks and [ __ ] to compete with Rogan
right as a black belt I think if you're
really big and strong it cuts through a
lot of years doesn't it it does it Brian
yeah it does is the rock at his age
you're looking at I mean come up a
little black belt and a dude dude with
your strength against a black belt yeah
even with thieves my size a black belt
you rolled up I know that I know but
after a year of you training with henna
in here on after a year hold it
destroyed and I'm a black belt destroyed
and he's my size because you're wrong
about that what do I know that you're
right Brian you're not useless but
you're wrong you trained you trained for
a preacher for six years you trained for
one year when you got up with a regular
black belt like me my size you're
telling me that he was he was tapping
him out oh yeah
Oh legit black belt without any big guy
in the world here's how I know but if
you're here obviously like super
trainings are just super easy especially
especially if
suggest if it's just jack miss don't be
wrong I saw I saw exceptions Brian I'm
tell me why are those exceptions right
slurs Ryan I'm that's the difference
right I'm taking a rustically like that
Bubba I'd lived it homeboy and I'm
telling my but you guys don't see modest
I'm not to tell me we'd get NFL guys in
who trained for 2-3 years
Brian Ortega would annihilate them in 13
seconds annihilate them
yeah Brian Ortega is an exception but
that's that's the special thing about
Joe I've seen my entire career where the
big guy comes in he's there for a year
and he loses confident you don't see him
anymore
he's gets [ __ ] um that's the thing
about aachen time I I belong just for me
like training wise I prefer I'm
obsessive about Malita I love trained
wait I I love it but this the real
special thing about jiu-jitsu is that
what Brandon's talking about is very
very unique in in combat if you took
it's an at-at former NFL player like an
exceptional athlete that's big and
strong and you gave him six months of
jiu-jitsu lessons and he really took it
seriously Kron Gracie had a hundred
forty pounds still gonna choke the
[ __ ] [ __ ] up he's so good I did you
make him go to sleep
he's what if you took you know a high
level NFL athlete and you gave him six
months of boxing he could hold his own
he could be big he if you know the
modeling like a really talented athlete
that's big and strong and you just
taught him how to throw a light I mean
he do stuff [ __ ] because a really good
boxer so you got at all 47 pounder in
there you know who's been throwing his
right hand ever since he's gonna light
yeah I'd still put my money on a
professional boxer but my point is is
that he can protect himself stay out if
you're a great athlete it's like the
difference like baseball's the same way
it doesn't matter how high you jump how
fast you run if you're a gifted athlete
you can't play baseball yeah you're
right I mean when you're really when
you're a big-time strong athlete you're
a 270-pound 206 pound a fleet and you're
you're wrestling or jiu-jitsu lling with
a guy who's 165 you have a huge
advantage if you're athletic you have a
huge advantage you're gonna be able to a
little technique goes a long way you it
goes a long way longer wait so for
instance that we
I've seen how this plays out so had art
gracie trains he was a six or seven time
pro baller he'd go to his instagram he
just post about him
this kid used this guy this grown man
he's from Afghanistan for African
descent forget his name play for the
Kansas City Chiefs pro baller three
years jiu-jitsu he's a blue belt every
black belt at the great economy would
steamroll this dude on a daily basis
that guy right there that guy right
there
o-69 pro baller Brian three years of
Jews dude he's a blue belt as a blue
belt every smaller from small guy to the
heavier black belts would absolutely
have to see never my eyes because I have
trouble believing it I just do
understand you I've lived it brother I
know I don't you know baby dead hands
house I'm telling for ten years I was in
the juicer gym we'd have big guys come
in there and they get [ __ ] up yeah I
know that get [ __ ] up that the guys
who get fired black belts will [ __ ] them
up but big big wrestlers I've seen white
belt college wrestlers that come in that
are Jack went up today about wrestling I
know I just bought wrestlers have
different bears it's thing about
high-level wrestlers freestyle wrestlers
if they're jack enough their bait
doesn't matter how good your bases to
the other base isn't good you know he's
a freak of all freaks by the way just a
crazy ass six-time pro baller I mean let
the leaves and training a lot huh I
watched Henner I mean you watch ten are
like 275 pounds Brian Ortega ties him in
not yeah and not just do is based off
the little med that's what it's for
there's there's plenty of YouTube videos
of like world Strongest Man vs. Jiu
Jitsu guy or like I think there's one I
think it's Clark Gracie it may have been
it's a Gracie taking on a giant
bodybuilder dude and it's you know it's
just a matter of time it's just a matter
of time humbly that doesn't it freak man
out the freak of all freaks I would put
myself high on the if you count me as a
celebrity which I don't really count but
if there was a celebrity Muay Thai fight
I'll throw myself high on the list cuz
I've even trained him for effort I have
for a long time and I I love it I taste
it in my mouth when I'm on my way you
like it and I I don't think people throw
in ever
I do a lot but in the head yeah but I
I know like when I'm fighting real
competitive Muay Thai fighters they're
not they're not nutty enough but they'll
[ __ ] me but I definitely I know what
it's like the difference between getting
my my head snap back and then someone
who's like just moving around yeah the
one I take from this conversation is
very exciting for me because I'm gonna
train and I'm gonna take my jiu-jitsu
super suit seriously and in 10 years you
piece of [ __ ] it's coming and it's gonna
be surf and turf but it's gonna be
mostly turf it's gonna notice to start
cryin and now I'm gonna surf you cuz
you're gonna be on the turf okay you
understand me when I'm done with you I'm
gonna get on you like this and I'm a
surf you cuz you're gonna be passed out
and I'm gonna surf you so I'm gonna get
you on the turf and then I'm gonna surf
you dude and that's my I hate to be
shitty don't put your finger near me
about your hit here in ten years let's
go to current events fine on that note
I'm gonna let's have a grappling match
when this lockdowns over and I'm not
gonna train at all you versus I'm
training nothing dude all right do you
trip but I don't I don't I don't I
haven't trained I haven't put on Aggie
or rash guard in six months well that
yeah but you're still training a lot are
you a purple belt a blue belt well I
would love to roll with you but you
you're strong guy and you're young and
athletic and you've trained a long time
right variance dude I hold and forever
but I would love to we'll do it you'll
beat me but don't beat me up are we
gonna hook takedowns from the from the
standing position any jujitsu
competition that's ever existed careful
now right here outs in high school and I
don't wrestle at all I have no refuge
wrestle in high school no Bryan dude
yeah yeah I'm say you could just blast a
double life after high school
how much eat okay guy okay let's not and
I am I in solo Bell hey let's not Oh
let's before you have to high school out
army before attachment he says he was
grown on my history American team and
that's not true at all
I kid never anything you've ever hydlide
I said I saw a mountain lion talking
lying so you're gonna wrestle in college
we know this kind of mid-shin okay so
and he said podcast anything did this
great
we're gonna roll you guys gonna fight hi
I'm gonna five minutes oh [ __ ] soon I'm
gonna choke you so hard so you you are
gonna be surprised that your hands will
be a little more full than you expect I
believe that you can you'll probably
take me down because you do have the
experience in judo and all that like
where you like when I'm gonna wrap my
legs around you and you're gonna get a
cold oh you're gonna get a feel of my
grip and you're gonna go oh [ __ ] what
have I done and your nightmares will
come true you're strong kid I'm gonna
grab your arm and yank it across again
I'm gonna triangle you too and I'm not
gonna give up when you tap and I'm gonna
put him asleep and I'm gonna get up and
I'm gonna I'm gonna probably teabag you
through my pant really get a foam in
your mouth now now um I got some tricks
up my sleeve I carry a small knife tiny
knife I'm gonna cut you up a little bit
mark you up your back and stuff like
that you got a nice skin I'm jealous of
it so I'm gonna carve you up you're
shredded I'm gonna shred you up those in
the Boston Market and my elbows might
open up to a couple [ __ ] a couple
streaks on your face you elbow me and
I'm gonna push you off and I get up I'm
gonna let kick you so [ __ ] hard
that's what I like you're gonna you're
literally gonna cry this is like in
front of other grocery I guess you never
see me jump over leg kicks have you what
will happen is you'll go I have to jump
over and I'll catch the bladder and
you're [ __ ] like a football player
getting depleted like a wide receiver
come across me that you're fat over walk
into the ground and I will fall over
laughs well I want to promote this I'll
be the Dana White it's me for 99 what
are you lift a lot you can move a lot of
weight are you very strong yeah I mean
I'm not like him but I for a guy my size
I'm what do you what do you deadlift
hey what are you deathless five twenty
oh my god what are you dead left Brian
not even does more not even not even
mine oh I don't need you answer he
doesn't know
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]